[Music]
suddenly it seems the entire country is
talking about the alt-right so i guess
it's our turn as well
for those of you who are attuned to the
wacky wild underside of the internet you
know that the alt-right has existed for
a couple years now
but it's only in the last few days that
the mainstream has started talking about
it
last week hillary clinton attacked the
alt-right in a big speech
which led to coverage in every newspaper
and online
outlet across the globe hillary blamed
breitbart.com
for mainstreaming racism which she said
was proven
by trump's embrace of the alt-right cnn
and fox news both aired clips from the
rubin report in which milo yiannopoulos
talked about the alt-right
explaining it as a counter-culture
movement uniting
disaffected conservatives with
mischievous
internet meme makers the usual pundits
suddenly were all
experts on the alt-right even though
they didn't know what it was
while it was growing right before their
eyes this whole time our outrage
culture always needs some new outrage to
be outraged about and once hillary
mentioned the alt-right by name
it meant the movement had officially
arrived
the alt-right seems to take many
different forms depending on who you
talk to
mainstream media and pretty much the
entire left brand the alt-right as a
white supremacist movement
rallying around donald trump their
members hate blacks they hate jews they
hate hispanics
and they want some sort of racially pure
country to stop
white genocide mainstream republicans
see the alt-right as
a group of loudmouth defensive racists
who are tearing the conservative
movement apart
by throwing away traditional
conservative ideals like small
government
and replacing them with a
win-at-all-cost candidate
others say the alt-right is a grassroots
movement born out of natural pushback
to our increasingly political correct
society i think if you mix some of those
explanations together you get what the
all
right really is but you have to add one
more thing
the internet the alt-right whatever
version of it you claim to be was
created right here on the internet
and as something created by the internet
it is as
amorphous as the internet itself what
the alt-right
really is though is a band of meme
posters
anime avatars and twitter eggs vying for
attention from people in power
they post nazi memes racist pictures and
offensive tweets with the express
intent of getting powerful people to
react
respond and thus amplify their message
they are keyboard warriors and
professional trolls trying to get
attention from the sold out and corrupt
media
and political elite that we have the
real alt-right
isn't about one political ideology as
much it
as it is a loosely linked group of
people using the tools of the
internet to upset the establishment
ironically in some ways this wrangling
and mocking of the establishment is
exactly what the bernie revolution was
supposed to be
but while hillary put bernie's
revolution on ice she has now
elevated the alt-right to mainstream
status by giving a big speech about it
the alt-right wants attention more than
anything and they
trolled her into giving them exactly
what they want
let me back up here for a sec because i
don't want to gloss over that whole
white supremacist hate the blacks hate
the jews kick out the hispanics thing
this portion of the alt-right absolutely
does exist
i see it on twitter every single day you
can pause this video right now and find
thousands of images
including nazi imagery racist
caricatures of minorities and plenty
more
do a quick search on twitter scan on
reddit or a look at 4chan and you'll see
some pretty nasty stuff
i don't like it but you guys know my
policy on free speech
and free expression so i choose to
ignore these images and ideas rather
than amplify them
the real question though is do these
truly hateful racist
memes and tweets represent a real
movement of hate
or are they designed just to get
attention i think it's some combination
of both
some true racists mixed with a bunch of
people who just want to mess with those
in power
how many of each of them are there we
have no idea
what we do know though is that these
people wield
very little real world power
do white supremacists exist yeah do
black jew and hispanic haters exist yeah
they do
do some people want to keep immigrants
out because of racism
yes but the people who make up the
alt-right aren't the ones with the power
instead they are the ones trying to
upset the people in power
and as for donald trump he has blacks
and jews and hispanics on his campaign
staff
this doesn't mean there aren't racist
supporters of trump
of course there are just as there are
racist supporters of hillary and
everyone else to ever run for president
ever trump's blunt language which has
attacked almost every group out there
often blurring the line between being
politically incorrect and truly hateful
is just an extension of the tactics that
the alt-right keyboard warriors are
doing on their own
personally i think that the regressive
left
is more of a threat to our democracy
than the alt-right the regressive
left with its tactics of stifling debate
and silencing critics
has gained mainstream traction in our
media and in our universities
these regressive not progressive ideas
have become all too common on the left
and they've actually given
birth to the natural response the
alt-right
i know this firsthand not only from the
emails that you guys send me but also
from all the students
at ucla who came up to me after my event
with milo yiannopoulos a couple months
ago
to tell me that they're supporting trump
just because they can't take the culture
of fear around
speech anymore the alt-right with its
trump
frogs and photoshop pictures of sick
hillary is little more than a bunch of
guys in their basements
using outrage culture against itself
most of us are not part of the
regressive left or the all-right this is
precisely why we must talk about ideas
honestly
and not let the extremes on either side
control the debate
as i've said many times before trump's
wall might not be sensible or sound
policy but a wall in and of itself is
not
racist if we refuse to have a
conversation about immigration
without yelling racist and everyone who
disagrees with us
then we'll leave the conversation to
anyone who comes up with an easy answer
trump's wall is the easy answer to a
complex immigration problem
and it's one of the reasons that the
alt-right loves him
the alt-right is the organic result of a
politically correct
society that refuses to engage in ideas
in an honest way
that doesn't mean the alt-right is right
it just means that they're here and to
demonize them without understanding them
doesn't stop them
it actually strengthens them my guest
this week is scott adams scott is the
creator of the nationally syndicated
comic strip
dilbert as well as a proponent of donald
trump's
tactics i don't know if he considers
himself part of the alt-right but i
would consider him part of it
as someone who's using internet culture
to spread his ideas
during this insane election cycle we're
going to dive into
his feelings about donald trump and much
more will the alt-right
twitter nazis make memes of us in nazi
costumes after the interview
you'll only know if we retweet them
[Music]
ourselves
you